contrary to this new movement about
ideas and dialogue and platforming and
hearing everybody out I think it's
important at some point to insert what
should be a pretty obvious reality to us
which is that no matter what
conversations you want to have or you
choose to have or you enable the halving
of
you can't find middle ground with crazy
people not every idea deserves to be
part of the discussion not every person
can be part of the solution and some
people and their ideas have to be
ignored have to be kept out of the
discussion or we are going to truly
damage ourselves as a species as a human
society as a country however you want to
slice and dice it now before people go
crazy and start writing in saying David
you're calling for censorship you're
calling for mistreatment of people you
are limiting people's First Amendment
rights and limiting what people have to
say I'm not okay this came up last week
during the interview I did with Joe
Rogan in Los Angeles there's lots of
great things about this movement of the
last several years that says it wants to
hear all ideas and it wants to figure
out what's best and have in-depth
discussion was with people from all
sides of the political spectrum that's
great okay I've been doing it for ten
years on the show dialogue is good
discourse is critical to human
advancement a diverse range of opinions
should be heard and considered and
evaluated when we are trying to figure
out as humans what is best for our
future and what's best for our societies
but there are people out there with
outrageously extreme bad ideas and it's
okay to put the line somewhere and say
you don't get a seat at the table we're
going to figure this thing out without
you because your ideas are terrible and
crazy and dangerous in some cases now of
course the devil is in the details and
who is it that Gates gets that sort of
gatekeeping power that's a real question
but during the Joe Rogan interview I
pointed out I'm one of the biggest
advocates of conversations with people
we disagree with respectful debate the
marketplace of ideas responsible
platforming of extremism even but that
at a certain point you
can't have reasonable conversations with
some people I gave the example if we're
trying to figure out what the top
marginal tax rate should be in modern
Western countries like ours that have
economic systems that depend on
government revenue already what role is
there for someone who thinks all taxes
are government slavery right you have to
do the responsible thing and not give
that person a seat at the table when it
comes down to actually making policy
okay you want to do a TV show and have
someone from the taxes or slavery camp
do it you want to have an academic
debate about taxation bring the taxes or
slavery people but when we're trying to
figure this out in the serious
legislative sense does that person
demand or rather deserve a seat at the
table no it's just an interruption it's
going to get in the way of actually
figuring things out when we're trying to
figure out the issue of it being legal
still now in 2019 in a bunch of states
to fire people based on their sexual
orientation real or perceived sexual
orientation should a lawmaker or a voter
who believes that gay people should be
put to death have a seat at the table in
that conversation no it would be
irresponsible it would be ridiculous to
give that person a seat at the table
there's nothing wrong with this okay
it's called modern society in philosophy
there's something called the Hegelian
dialectic it's named after Hegel a
German philosopher from the late 18th
early 19th century and the basic idea of
the Hegelian dialectic is that the
process of change comes from the process
of figuring things out maybe is a better
way of saying it it comes from a thesis
and then an antithesis or an antithesis
and then a synthesis of the two into
some kind of path forward the underlying
idea is that we're constantly merging
opposed ideologies that will get us
closer to an ideal or a solution or
perfection of some kind to use a utopian
idealistic term this doesn't work with
outrageous bad faith ignorant or
cognitively limited people and horrible
ideas period we need to stop
going so far into the marketplace of
ideas to the point where it becomes self
destructed by map its destructive rather
when we mandate that all ideas be
considered equally and given equal
footing we are actually ceding ground to
extremism and this is not an
hypothetical this is how the right has
won many victories if eventually the
solution is going to end up as the
midpoint or the average or the mean of
all ideas by presenting the most extreme
possible ideas you pull the average to
your side Republicans know this the
right know this knows this and they've
used it successfully if the debate over
abortion is about up until what point in
a pregnancy should abortion be legal and
we sort of concede that we're going to
end up in the middle of all of the
suggestions that we get the
anti-abortion right is incentivized to
straight up say all abortions should be
illegal at one day of pregnancy abortion
is illegal and if we guarantee that
crazy position a seat at the table they
win by suggesting the craziest possible
idea and pulling the Overton Window
pulling the average of the debate over
to their side if the debate over the
highest marginal tax rate is going to
end up as the average of all the
proposed ideas the right benefits by
saying the tax rate should be zero or
taxation is slavery because it pulls the
average towards them I wish Democrats
had understood this longer ago if they
had decided not to seed a ton of ground
to Republicans trying to negotiate over
things that Republicans simply will not
negotiate about we would be far better
off today if you do a show and you want
to hear out wacky ideas do it I do it on
this show as long as I'm prepared to
responsibly do it pushing back against
them giving an opposing view but when
we're trying to have the serious
conversations we don't have any
responsibility to let just any crazy old
notion into the discussion when a new
plane is being developed there's a
cut-off as to what ideas Boeing or
Airbus allow into the discussion and who
is allowed to contribute to the planes
this
anything else would be ridiculous when
we consider the best treatment for a
medical condition not every crazy notion
is given the same value this is logical
it shouldn't be different with politics
this isn't censorship everyone can say
whatever they want say it on YouTube go
to your local City Council meeting and
say it write a letter to your elected
officials do a podcast whatever but you
can't negotiate with crazy people and
their crazy ideas and they don't have to
be given a seat at the big-boy table and
that's okay period let me know if you
disagree